what's new is that we are putting a lot
more
investment number one into tackling the
300 000 problem drugs users who drive
about half of acquisitive crime and
about half of the homicides in this
country crime has been coming down
overall in the last couple of years but
we're seeing a lot of problems caused by
these 300 000 problem drugs users so
what we're doing is we're ramping up our
campaign against the the county lines uh
networks that are that are preying on
these users you've got to invest in
rehabilitation everybody who knows about
drugs crime will tell you that 300 000
people their lives that are chaotic they
need to be taken off drugs they need to
be put into rehab you've got to invest
in rehab but you've also got to come
down hard on the gangsters who are who
are making hell of people's lives we
want everybody to be able to grow up in
safer streets everybody to have the
right to have a safe community to grow
up in and too many people have their
lives blighted by these county lines
gang so you've got to have you've got it
you've got to do two things at once
you'll be tougher on
the counter lines gangs gonna be tougher
on the on the uh the criminals who are
doing it but you've also got to make
sure that you you find those 300 000
people and you help them away you can't
simply arrest them time after time and
put them back in prison again again
you've got to do rehab as well what
we're also saying
is that we're not going to
sit idly by when you have a lifestyle
users also
using class a drugs and we're going to
be coming down tougher on them but this
is about
being very very tough on county lines
gangs ramping that up we've already
wrapped we've already rolled up about
1500 uh counter lines gangs we want to
do 2000 more labour say there's been 100
million pounds cuts in drug treatment
they've been cut to police budgets over
many years they're right aren't they
no we're putting well so since this
government came in uh we've not only put
11 000 more police on the streets as
part of our commitment to put another 20
000 more about to when announcing
another 300 million to tackle county
lines gangs don't forget so far just in
the last couple of years uh under under
project adder all the other anti-county
lines uh projects that we've got canton
operations we've we've rolled up wrapped
up about 1500 networks of of about 5000
or so we're going to do another 2 000
and what would what we're doing is
taking the the kids who are vulnerable
whose lives are being lost on the
streets of this country because of the
county lines gangs putting them into
care so it's uh
what this government is saying is we
understand that the drugs
gangs are doing major damage to life
chances of kids growing up in this
country i think it is a it is a
disgusting trade and we need to fight it
so you're going to take the passports
away from middle class
drug users
well we're looking at doing things to
tackle
those so-called lifestyle drugs users
who don't think that they're part of the
problem
in the end all the demand is helping to
create the problem the the 300 000
problem drugs use it you've got to deal
with what's going on there you've got to
make sure that they're given rehab
you've got to come down tough on the
county lines gangs but you've also got
to think about what's happening with the
demand the the the uh
the the economic advantage that is given
to the drugs gangs by the lifestyle
drugs users as well sunday times
reported that a lot of cocaine use found
in the toilets of parliament and the
public trust mps on this issue look this
government is absolutely determined to
to fight
drugs and to make sure i i take a i take
the view that it's a long time really
since you've heard a government say
that drugs uh class a drugs are bad and
bad for society bad for opportunity bad
for kids growing up in this country
that's my view and i think and i think
it's something that we can we can tackle
we can deal with you've got it you've
got to be realistic you've got to be
humane you've got to be compassionate
you've got to recognize that
overwhelmingly the problem is caused by
300 000 people whose lives are simply
chaotic uh who are who are
torn apart by their own addiction you've
got to help them you've got to do rehab
but you've also got to come down very
very hard on the county lines gangs and
that's what we're doing uncovered senior
scientists have said you've brought the
travel uh testing in too late it's
bolting this door after the
the horses bolted what do you say to
that no i think that what we're doing is
responding to the uh the pandemic we
were the first country in the uh in the
in the world to
take measures decisive measures to
tackle omicron if you remember we put
about uh 10 countries automatically
immediately into
onto the red list and we said that
anybody coming from any country in the
world uh would have to uh to quarantine
for a couple of days we're now going
further and uh and toughening those
measures up as we as we see the spread
of omicron around the world but i think
what we need to do everyone just
just for
everybody to understand i don't think
that we need to change the overall
guidance and advice we're giving about
omicron in this country we're still
waiting to see
exactly
how dangerous it is
what sort of
effect it has in terms of deaths and and
hospitalizations can you say for certain
though that we won't face social
restrictions before christmas
i
i said i think many times now that i
think that this christmas will be
considerably uh better than last
christmas uh with and with the possible
exception uh for the county lines drugs
gangs that we intend to roll up uh today